what is the power of objective
observation oh this is my favorite thing
we could we could heal the whole planet
just on objective observation it's rare
but it's the most important thing for an
artist I think of all the tools and the
toolkit objective observation I think
actors do it
um I was going to say painters do that
uh
all the time they're always looking and
when they look and they observe
objectively not with judgment they don't
look at a tree and say oh tree not nice
and they're left good on the right not
so good on the left
painters look at things to see what they
haven't seen before
objective observation is the art of just
looking
just looking no judgment
so if I say to just look just spend 10
minutes looking without judgment can you
see that is a rare rare thing we don't
do that and one of the reasons we don't
slow down enough you have to slow down
you have to steal yourself so it's
another way to get into a meditative
state but for an artist when you look
objectively without judgment
you can discover what you haven't seen
before
so most of us look and see and go I know
that I got it check
you know that's it
there's no more learning there's no more
discovery
but if you walk by in New York I have
this tree outside the apartment that I'm
very fond of and that I look at Daily
when I'm in New York
and I I I will just spend
history objectively thoughts
Drift Away emotions worry everything
just went just look at the tree and look
at the spaces between the leaves I look
at the leaves and
you know this is me but I swear you do
that and a breeze will come up and the
tree will go like this and wave at you
you'll see you know a bird make a nest
at the top all of these things are
happening around you and available to
you
all of the time but you have to steal
yourself and look and you have to be
aware
of how much judgment you have because
we're trained to it you know we're all
walking around with so much judgment you
know and and social media isn't helping
us I like it I don't like it I the
things that people say to people on
social media are just it's unfathomable
to me
um so those people are a little asleep
and we we have you set an example and
then something else becomes cool we have
to try
we have to try to make Awakening hip we
have to try to make Awakening
Consciousness cool and there you know
there are lots of people waking up at
the same time so we'll we'll find a way
to to make people you know want to do
that more but objective observation is
the artist's greatest tool because it
allows them to see what they think they
know and discover what they didn't see
before
and when you work with someone how can
you tell that maybe they haven't awoken
that part yet
that they don't have it in them at this
point well they well it's because it
starts with the first exercise the
environment exercise where they create a
space
because the exercises go in your life
study your life's rhythms
study how you make coffee study how you
make breakfast study how you shave study
you know all these different life where
the guy who studied how we got dressed
for work
in his police job these are all life
rhythms that we do them over and over
and over again and when we look at those
objectively and discover the behavior we
didn't see before and then duplicate
that behavior so then they come to the
exercise and there's not enough Behavior
I can tell that they haven't been
looking for it so then I have them go
back and make a list and bring me the
list what are the behaviors I mean
here's a perfect example my my husband
was shaving
one morning and you know we work
together and and when the studio was
open he was there all the time as well
so he's shaving in the morning and he
starts to observe objectively his
shaving exactly how he shaves and the
habits and you know we do all these
little things and then you finish
shaving and then he went to put his
contact lenses in he does these things
exactly the same every morning goes to
put his contact lenses and he puts a
contact lens in and he goes like this
and he said he went and he looked at a
painting that my father did of me across
the room and he looked at it with his
eye that's how he checked to see if the
contact was Cedar right then he put the
other one in and he looked at the
painting with that eye and he realized
he had been doing this for 12 years 15
and he had never realized
that he did this checking with the eyes
if you put that behavior into a movie
I'm telling you people will love it
because it's human behavior and
everybody knows it and it was discovered
he looked at what he does every day what
he knows how to do and he discovered
something he'd never seen before that's
art that's art discovery is art
you know I I looked for a definition
because I'm a teacher of art I wanted a
definition of art that would Inspire
that would light people up
I couldn't find it and I looked at a lot
of dictionaries and you know they talk
about creativity and they talk about all
kinds of things but nothing rang my bell
so I finally asked myself you know what
do I think this is what is this and it
came very clear to me you know that art
is the expression of that which you've
discovered
if you if there's no Discovery there's
no art it's going to be just you know a
rendition of something that you've seen
before that you liked you know and you
make a little rendition of that and
feels like it's good but if you discover
something now you have something
personal to give even if it's as small
as putting your contacts in and checking
and to see if they're seated right in
the picture then you'd have the shot of
the painting which is pretty dramatic
and then you have this shot of it I
don't know where you go from there but
it's a beautiful piece of behavior and
the story is told in Behavior
So when you say the word rendition if we
go back to asking an actor what do you
want what do you want from life oh well
I want to be famous I want to be in this
movie I want to do the next Blue Jasmine
I want and then you go wait a minute
do you really want to do that or is that
a rendition
of what you've that that's is is there
something that's more authentic to you
yeah I think that's true I don't want to
be hard on them if they love blue velvet
and they love you know there are all
kinds of things add up in them to an
excitement of wanting to be a filmmaker
I want to make films like that but if
you just direct them to this
ways to ask questions
if you direct them to these tools like
objective observation keeping your
vibration high with gratitude and you
know what should have so many blessings
anybody making a film has a lot of
blessings you know uh joyless things
there are several others but objective
observation is one of them you give them
these tools and they will begin to
listen to themselves you know the entire
book The my entire purpose of writing a
book
and I don't call it my book because you
know a lot of it just came through
um I called the book but the sole
purpose of it was can I use this
technique in these lessons that I've
learned in my life to help someone
listen
to the Muse in them listen to their own
soul speaking listen to that find that
place of inspiration where all of these
the same things come from that one space
which is
you know the in meditation they call it
the Gap it's a place without thought and
the longer you for me the longer I work
with it the more it creates this kind of
a space and it feels like peace it feels
like relaxation but if you ask questions
like why do I like blue velvet or you
know why do I want you know things will
come in and those things that come in
will move in you and then you'll know oh
that's that's what I want to do that's
that's the Muse that's speaking to me
that's my that's my purpose that's my
goal that's that's authentic that's a
discovery you discover you have an aha
moment you ask yourself and then you go
oh that's
that's charged that's gold that's what
you're looking for so the whole purpose
was to lead people to that space to
question
and uh listen for the right answers and
then teach them
this one's loaded go for that one go
after that
so it's the gap
the Gap is the space
and when you're in the gap which is
really the present moment you know when
you watch an actor who's you know all
the time
all the time people say you know
but you know actors say I want to live
in the moment you know this is the whole
movement in acting about being in the
moment is he in the moment is it going
to be in the moment and so people think
being in the moment is improvisational
being in the moment is not just
improvisational that's part of it to be
in the moment improvisationally okay
that's part of it but the moments are
created by you in your imagination from
this story that you want to tell
underneath the story so here's the
script and here's you know your choices
the script is
um
the tip of the iceberg and the actor's
work is the whole bottom of the iceberg
so you're going to create a story
underneath that screenplay that brings
that screenplay to life those choices
the more authentic the more aha the more
they're made from that space through
questions that you ask yourself over and
over until you go oh what if it was that
and you put that into the work in a
concrete way now you're cooking with gas
now you're really creating so there's no
worry about you know he likes this or I
had to worry about is he being authentic
is he not being authentic just lead them
to that space let them practice in that
space let them learn how to observe
objectively let them discover by
observing you know let them discover by
observing objectively and then let them
take that Discovery and put it into the
work and concrete way because it's not
enough for it to be in your head people
think oh I got this thing I have this
idea I think it's so great well if that
idea doesn't go into some form of
behavior some form of physical choice in
this scene
it it's all for naught it doesn't exist
the actors write long biographies I need
long biographies I need a biography that
has enough things that activate certain
behavioral choices in the scene
have you seen the most aha in a
performance in film or theater
that's a good question
you know what comes to mind the first
thing that comes to mind I can't believe
this comes to mind it was so long time
ago I saw Alex Guinness
uh in Dylan on Broadway
so the end of this play you know Dylan
Tom about Dylan Thomas he builds you
know he's been told if you have another
drink you're going to die you cannot
drink you're going to die so he goes
into the White Horse Tavern and he
builds he orders I don't know 40 shot
glasses and he builds a tower of these
shot glasses he built very carefully
builds and one on top of another on top
of another on top of another
and then the very last moment of the
play he takes the top one off and shoots
the thing and there's a blackout
right
I didn't realize I had watched him Build
That Power with no words
just full-on inner life
I don't know 15 minutes 10 minutes
that's very brave thing to do in a play
and I had entered it
I was he you know we enter the character
we don't just go into the White Horse
Tavern we enter the character we
experience what he's experiencing
which helps us you know to realize the
genius of actors
if we can enter his experience we can
certainly enter that for our fellow man
if we started entering each other's
experiences a little bit more and caring
a little bit more that that's why I
think acting reverberates
with people so much why we love artists
and we love performance but I don't
think we're aware
that that's why